[Musique]
et l'objectif c'est de mobiliser la
population francilienne pour donner son
sang et quand je parle de la population
francilienne je parle naturellement des
donneurs qui vient déjà nous voir et
qu'une rencontre warduni rançon de
collecte mais je parle également des
personnes qui n'ont pas encore osé
franchir le cap et qui n'ont pas encore
eu le réflexe de venir nous rejoindre
sur une colle est la période estivale
est une période qui est difficile dans
la mesure où des produits sanguins de
fléchissement des demandes auprès des
centaines d'oeufs fléchit pas les
patients vous savez ils prennent pas de
vacances
les patients tous les joueurs ont besoin
d'être pris en charge ils sont encore
plus important cette année dont nous
constatons actuellement que la demande
en produits sanguins d'une très élevé et
très élevée tout simplement après la pub
kovy douillet beaucoup de
déprogrammation actuellement les
services hospitaliers tourne à plat
voire même tout homme de manière plus
importante qu'en temps normal
et de fait la demande en produits
sanguins est extrêmement importante il
nous devons collectivement y faire face
il ya de très nombreuses collectes qui
se déroule actuellement d'île de france
vous pouvez retrouver tous nos lieux de
collecte sur notre application
don du sang sur notre site internet
et pour donner son sang c'est très
facile vous allez sur notre site
internet vous trouverez la collecte la
plus proche de chez vous vous pourrez
prendre rendez vous